how do you create a world that's modable
so you you think of Designing the game
from the start as that enables mods yeah
absolutely
so it starts with us like everything
we're doing okay a modder a content
creator is going to have to do it use
our tools now we do clean them up for
release you know because if you're like
a developer in-house you can deal with
some clergyness when you're putting
stuff together when you put it out for
people we do clean a lot of it up and
there's still a lot obviously a learning
curve there
um but we have look we have people been
doing it for 20 years with us
um what's involved with modding I'm
actually quite newbish at this okay and
I'm almost afraid to ask because now
that you explained to me oh I I fear I
will spend a very large amount of time
creating mods well we have an editor uh
you can download on Steam the creation
kit for our games and then it loads up
the world and you could do something
really really small like change the
color of the weather and it creates a
little plug-in file we call it you know
a modification to the game and then you
can run your game with that
um it's on Console now that the mods not
the editing
and it's just been incredible our
community there has been amazing what
they do with the games so a lot of it is
the the the visuals a lot of people do
visual things because it's the easiest
thing to do first or to build a new
space there's some great things with
like I love the Khajiit uh follower mod
for Skyrim it's awesome
um the uh there have been quest lines
those things just take a really really
long time and so someone is going to do
that
that's almost like it takes them a long
time it's more than a hobby and we're
always looking at ways that we can make
it like hey they can turn a career into
it because it's just awesome
what about is is there any possibility
in doing a mod for the some of the AI
stuff
there is and I've seen some but to
really move it along if they're using
the tools that we already put out there
so to really move the AI along you'd
have to get in the code which some
people have figured out ways to hack in
and do things with script extenders but
for the most part like really pushing it
it does take us which is why you see
when we have a new game come along the
palette that they have is there's
there's so many more things they can do
well I've I've built Bots that play
um the the driving games
but they do that by just taking
um reading the screen and doing basic
not basic it's actually pretty
complicated but computer vision doing
the control but you're basically
simulating the human player
um to do that for Skyrim or for what
some of the open world games that's
literally you have to create AGI to be
able to yep to play the those open well
maybe not maybe you can create a super
dumb like just a two-handed sword and
just keep swinging until look there's
some bot stuff out there that does it we
have we have some very very dumb Bots
that we use to run through the world to
test it that will Deploy on a whole
bunch of servers just to you know we do
it every day we run through every space
we're doing Starfield and then just
running they're all out there well it
does it very quickly it loads up every
place every
every place in the game and runs around
a little bit and then loads the next
place and runs around a little bit we're
just testing like did a crash what's the
memory growth what's the get a report
hear all the places where the frame rate
wasn't up to Snuff
and then we do have one that will play
on its own it's heavily scripted but it
lets us test
you know every time we make a build
there's a bot that runs through like the
first one or two main quests like it'll
just play it that way we know do we
break anything
because you don't want to waste like
qa's time like you guys broke it again
within five minutes so yeah
yeah so that's for but that's for like
uh broken stuff right I wonder if you
can build the bot that estimates the
quality of the experience oh my gosh
okay can you do that but just like the
number
like how boring or not boring the boring
meter how many times you die
how many times you die death is death
boring or exciting that's the question I
mean I I feel like there's a balance to
be stuck there because you always want
to be in fear of death again yeah we
always we have this chart at work we use
which is like if you think about any
game that you've played that you've put
down it's either about a frustration
slash confusion or boredom
yeah you gotta put the player right in
the middle of that but I've sometimes
put down games from frustration only to
return again stronger Dark Souls yeah
so I mean that that's I mean the
challenge
that's part of it it's well I don't know
actually Skyrim I don't I'm one of those
I mean I'm sure there's all kinds of
humans that you've interacted with about
what they enjoy but to me I could enjoy
Skyrim on every on any difficulty at the
level it doesn't all of it so it depends
the open world nature of it is what's
really compelling not necessarily the
challenge of the particular quests and
so on but I'm not sure if that's the
same experience for everybody do you
play the survival mode there's a
survival mode in Skyrim it was a
creation Club thing it does like some
Hunger it does hot and cold
it does some other systems that make it
you know in our minds a more believable
it was actually a creation Club thing
made by an external Creator who is now
full time with us